well let's speak now to dr. Hamid Khan
of the BMA he's here in the studio and
Rachael Clarke a junior doctor who joins
us live from Oxford good evening to you
both dr. Clark start with you the BMA
had recommended this as the best deal
junior doctors were going to get so why
vote against it it's very simple and
Jeremy Hunt in a way put it very
eloquently in his own words he's still
talking about his government so-called
manifesto pledge for a seven-day NHS
what he has fails to hear for an entire
year is our objection to the notion that
a seven-day NHS can be delivered with no
funding and no extra staffing the NHS is
already desperately underfunded and
frontline junior doctors like me are on
our knees pretty much every day that we
go into work that's even before he
attempts to stretch services even more
thinly over seven days there are no more
doctors he's not delivering any more
doctors he's not delivering any
resources this seven-day NHS was always
a fiction that he has used as a stick to
beat junior doctors like me and we have
said no over and over again the thing
none of us can understand now is why he
still refuses to listen Jerry Hunt has
pointed out though dr. Rachael Clarke
that only forty percent of those
eligible to vote rejected the contract a
third didn't vote at all what happens
now absolutely I mean I think it would
be a grave error to assume that the
doctors who did vote for the contracted
so as an endorsement of the contract I
am one of that food I voted for the
contract with a very heavy heart very
reluctantly because I saw it as a bad
option but the least worst option in the
new brexit climate that we face I think
what has to happen now and if Jeremy
Hunt has any concerns about patient
safety he would strive to do this he
needs to recognize and here our concerns
and he needs to address them he needs to
stop hiding behind rhetoric at the
moment there are gaps in all our rotors
he needs to address those he needs to
find ways of filling the gaps with
new doctors he means to recognize that
currently doctors do not receive
adequate training they have no whistle
blowing protection whatsoever in the NHS
they're the only group of employees in
the NHS that have that lacked that
protection and he needs to address that
what he has to stop doing is spinning
actions speak louder than words and he
needs to start acting in a way that can
rebuild the corrosive and devastating
effect he has had on the trussell wrong
doc doesn't dr. Clark are we going to
see further strike action I think that's
a very real possibility I think right
now the stakes are high and there is a
window in which the Department of Health
and Jeremy Hunt by her actions could do
something to address this situation he
used to pretend this entire dispute was
the making of the BMA that somehow we
had been whipped up into a frenzy by our
militant union well the vote today
proves that that is is not accurate this
is an opposition Eric's bring in dr.
Hamid car on on that point about the BMA
I mean there are those who say that the
poisonous atmosphere this is all down to
the poisonous atmosphere that has
emerged in this very bitter dispute that
whatever Jeremy Hunt was going to say
wasn't going to be accepted does the
beer may bear some responsibility for
that no I don't think it does to the
contrary the BMA has tried its best to
come up with a solution in a very
difficult situation the Health Secretary
has deliberately toxify the atmosphere
around these talks he has turned this
into a bitter confrontational dispute
and it never had to be he did so by
calling the BMA radicalized by using the
term militant for doctors even spoke
about nuclear options and at worst he
even associated the Paris attacks and
tried to scare the public by suggesting
that we wouldn't work if there was a
terrorist attack here if we were on
strike and it is the BMA didn't do any
stirring up at this debate you're saying
not at all not at all we have simply
tried to present the facts as best as we
could and if anything Johann marijuana
has tried as best to make things easier
for the government by giving them this
opportunities now gone so what happens
now what does this do for the
ability of the BMA who's going to be
there to negotiate this contract again
well that's very simple the BMA has
procedures there will be a new head of
the junior doctors committee and then
they will take negotiations forward but
that is the wrong premise the question
that we should be asking is how the
health secretary will change his
approach or whether the government will
have a new health secretary in place we
have a situation what this is about do
you think do you think this is about the
political uncertainty that we're
currently undergoing and that people
think junior doctors may think that
there may be a new health secretary
there may be an opportunity to get more
no I don't think this has been
opportunism at all the state of affairs
are such that we have the one of the
lowest levels of funding in the NHS out
of all developed countries the lowest in
the g7 group of countries we have a
health secretary who's deliberately
stoked up confrontation with the terms
that I just said and the fundamental
premise of this contract the seven-day
NHS is based on completely manipulated
flawed evidence to the extent that even
the authors of the report of the paper
rather which Jeremy Hunt keeps citing
have rubbished it they've said that it's
completely untrue so we need to get rid
of that premise we need to get rid of
this obsession with a so-called
seven-day NHS which is completely
undefined which is completely
unconscious ound bites dr. rachel clark
me Jeremy Hunt gave quite a lot of
ground in this dispute didn't he I mean
there were major concessions made on pay
and on working conditions and on
protections for people having to take
time out for example and are you
concerned that you could end up with a
worse deal I really don't see it in
those terms I'm afraid I don't think he
did concede very much at all and I think
that this vote demonstrates that the
contract we have on the table currently
is sexist it discriminates against women
it offers no whistleblower protections
junior doctors it does very little to
address the rotor gaps that are plaguing
every hospital in the country at the
moment and crucially at no stage
he ever acknowledged the fact that if he
really wants to deliver safer weed
cancer patient something that he and his
prime minister have claimed over and
over again the barrier to doing that is
not asked junior doctors it is the lack
of funds from central government and
until he addresses those fundamental
points he leaves junior doctors like me
feeling demoralized undermines cheapened
and humiliated by this dispute and i'm
afraid the first and most important act
he could do to rebuild this situation
would be to do the honorable thing and
resign okay dr. rachel clark and dr.
Hamid Khan thank you both very much
indeed